what's happened is tragically we created
a tremendous segregation yeah well we're
new underclass if you will an immigrant
underclass which Sweden never had mhm
and we don't know how to deal with it
and we're also running out of money
because we have the most expensive
welfare system in the world and now
we're trying to deal with it it nobody
knows what to do can you guys explain a
little bit about how the immigration
issue arose that basically this all
started just in the last really seven
years something like that but a pretty
much homogeneous society for better or
worse decided I think but correct me if
I'm wrong I think probably with good
intentions by people that weren't
thinking that much to bring in a ton of
people how many immigrants roughly have
come in over the last decade you can
take this one or if you take it over a
decade the numbers are always changing
because they're playing around with them
so it but it depends on how you kind of
calculate it but it is it is a bit over
a million people so it's a roughly a
tenth of the population yeah came in
let's say in the last decade from these
countries what do you think the leaders
thought exactly it was gonna happen
let's say well intentioned but do you
think maybe I'm giving them no no no
let's let's do the well intention
because I like to give people the
benefit of the doubt I think they were
hoping for a a multicultural Nirvana
with you know T Bob's you know and some
belly dancing yeah and that everyone
else a lot of smoked fish that is true
yeah but other than that I think the
idea is if you live in a culture that is
so homogenous as Sweden is you cannot
think outside the box of our own culture
they don't even perceive that we have a
culture they probably believe they will
become suites very quickly when they
realize how right and good we are yes
they will be also didn't happen go yeah
so if we were not to give them the
benefit of the doubt because I also I
try not to go to people's motives and I
think the road to hell is paved with
good intentions and I think a lot of
these people think
they're doing the right thing but it but
let's go to the non good motive
I think you just wrote a book about it
yeah I mean what what so think these
people thought they were doing or what
do you think they thought was going to
happen just when you change demographics
that much a tenth of a population is a
huge huge huge amount well I think they
won't wanted to him so the social
democrat came into power they actually
lifted up the working class to a much
better living standard and the idea was
as soon as we get them up to
middle-class living standards they will
become true communists and understand
that they need to devote everything to
the struggle what happened in reality
was that they were perfectly fine
whether flat-screen TVs they wanted more
flat-screen TVs and longer vacation time
they didn't want to join a communist
revolution they became in essence
well our equivalent of Republicans I
suppose so they needed new voters in a
sense and they in voted and then they
took in a lot of people into the most
over regulated labor market in the world
and these people second generation and
third generation immigrants they're not
getting into the system they're keeping
them for the ballots they want their
votes and they can they keep them on
subsidies and some of these kids they
see that the system is rigged against
them and they have no choice stable
because of course they will become
gangsters or go off and fight for Isis
after a while all of them obviously I
think it's important at this point to
remember that the people that came in
you know those individuals it's not
their fault inherently you know they
were invited that asked about the
intentions and good or bad or the people
that brought them in not these people's
no I'd like to think you know crowds
always go crazy but individuals are much
more reasonable you know and somebody is
you know fleeing a war you know I have
the deepest sympathy yes of course I
would do the same thing but it is
irresponsible if you have a so regulated
labor market and you you take in more
people than you can help it that it's
like you were throwing a party that goes
haywire on Facebook everyone's invited
you know I have drinks for 12 people
what what did they think that people
were gonna do
like what kind of jobs did they think
people were gonna have her did they
immediately say you're taken care of for
a year you know we hear these stories at
the government wanted to start a camel
farm in Gothenburg well that was one of
the one experiment for some and that's a
yeah that was crazy I'm sort of racing
I'm sort of racist yeah but no we can't
give you a proper job but we'll give you
some subsidies start a camel farm you
should be good at that and also we have
plenty of camels in Sweden no we don't
we have reindeer truly people come in
and as you said they're often fleeing
war you have sympathies with all these
people the government then says here's
some stuff but you can't you have it
forever although they sort of do have it
forever but not just that you can't
happen forever it's a limited amount of
stuff right we can't put you and then
you then they can turn around and say
see we're also racist because we didn't
make you millionaires at night one yeah
there exactly they get a flat they get a
minimum living subsidy subsidy but and
then they are expected to vote left and
that is what it looks like if you break
down the statistics of different
municipalities and how they vote I mean
in ruse and gone in malm it was like
eight seventy to ninety percent worked
it for the Social Democrat or the left's
yes yes I mean their view we have the
numbers for all of that but what's
happened is tragically we created a
tremendous segregation yeah well a new
underclass if you will an immigrant
underclass which Sweden never had mhm
and we don't know how to deal with it
and we're also running out of money
because we have the most expensive
welfare system in the world and now
we're trying to deal with it it nobody
knows what to do this is a sort of
dangerous question in a way but I think
these conversations always end up here
which is do you think in a weird way
this then breeds racism yes that good
intentioned people right you mean you
just made it very clear you have no
ill-will towards these people but then
these people come into these countries
they're given these things they demand
more the politicians use them for votes
and then good people who are not racist
but maybe don't have a lot of time to
think about all these things suddenly
start becoming kind of racist it's just
it's just a sad fact of humanity
absolutely and I think it goes
both ways I think the Swedes wanted to
invite poor people from the third world
to come and live in Sweden because they
wanted to feel good themselves but also
they thought everyone would want to
become Swedish of course but then they
get a lot of immigrants and the
immigrants look at the Swedish society
and they're like maybe I'm gonna keep
some of my own culture mmm because I
don't think this is so great
and if you were to sort of and also if
you keep them out of the system and you
never let them in and you stick them in
ghettos of course they will start to
hate you and there's a weird thing that
I think Europe has that America doesn't
have which is that if you were to
assimilate them more sort of push more
of a Swedish culture on them that would
be against Swedish nature in a bizarre
way where America we have a melting pot
here so come here with all of your
traditions and all of those things but
mix into the fabric of America where
Europe has more of a ghettoization of
culture this I think the reason America
can can do this better is because your
country is founded on the principle of
individuality and individuals whereas
Sweden is founded on the idea of
collectivism and that makes it really
hard to break the molds now I have a
good friend who's he's working he's
doing a lot of work with newly arrived
African boys and like the top question
this is Mustapha panjiri the the
question he is most often asked by these
guys it's like how do I make Swedish
friends I don't know they never will
open up I'm never in touch with them and
at the same time I mean this is like
again bringing tears to my eyes they
want to work they want to break into
becoming useful at the same time sweets
will be telling oh no how you should
behave no I couldn't possibly tell you
just beers be yourself
yes and they give nothing away because
they don't understand being so
collectivist like we have a very closed
very complicated culture and if we want
to invite people into our culture we
need to start you know you here we do it
this way
this is you know but that is considered
almost racist certainly socially
aggressive to tell people that well this
is how we do things around here we take
off our shoes before we call incoming
to someone's home that is quite unique
yeah yeah it's awesome the Japanese
although we're more sloppy than the
Japanese I think there are all these
unwritten rules of course there are but
for the longest time Swedes denied that
because it would be racist to admit we
had our own culture can you guys talk a
little bit about how how you
differentiate from some of the other
Nordic countries because as I said we
always point to the Nordic countries but
Sweden is the one that we really focus
on but it sounds from what I could tell
and I did visit Denmark and I visited
Finland and a couple other places
Denmark doesn't seem to have the
problems as much as well they did up
until they had those cartoonists
scandals and then they sort of
understood what it was all about
if you can't criticize Mohammed that's
basically blasphemy laws and no modern
Western state would stand for that if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist there all
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell